(Theme from Seinfeld)
- [Jonathan] When Seinfeld first started
none of us expected it to last.
I was in charge of the music,
I turned that mother out.
(finger snapping and
mouth popping with rhythm)
(audience laughter)
- [Narrator] Jonathan Wolff is the
man behind Seinfeld's iconic sound.
(Theme from Seinfeld)
But what even the most
dedicated fans may not realize,
is that the theme song was actually
different for every episode.
- I have no idea how many
themes we did for Seinfeld.
I knew that each monologue
was gonna be different,
'cause he tells different jokes.
The timing, the length,
had to be adjustable
in a way it would still hold water
and still sound like the Seinfeld theme.
Each monologue had its own recording
of the Seinfeld theme
to match those timings.
- Old people in Florida, they
drive slow and they sit low.
(Theme from Seinfeld)
Right?
- [Narrator] It all started
with a phone call from Jerry.
- Hello?
- [Man On Phone] Jerry?
- [Narrator] When Jonathan first
began to compose the theme,
he knew he wanted to use unique sounds
that didn't drown out Jerry's voice.
He ended up using his own
fingers and mouth as instruments.
(finger snapping and
mouth popping with rhythm)
- And I had his attention.
- [Jerry] It's like the
Declaration of Independence,
who's gonna read that?
- [Narrator] After that Jonathan
spent time watching Jerry on T.V.
He noticed something.
- I watched his HBO special,
and noticed that Jerry has a
lyrical delivery to his jokes.
And I put a clock on it, about 110.
And that became the tempo
of the Seinfeld theme.
The bass line for Seinfeld,
(piano music)
so simple.
It can start and stop for his jokes,
(piano music)
hold for laughs,
(audience laughter)
and in that way I could
architect each piece
of music for each monologue LEGO-style.
(piano music)
And that is how the
Seinfeld theme was born.
- [Jerry] Oh my God, this drawer
is filled with Froot Loops.
- [Narrator] In the end, Jonathan's music
almost didn't make it onto the show.
- Jerry loved the music,
Larry David loved the music.
Everybody on board, except the network.
The notes were: what is this music?
What is that instrument?
Could we not afford real music?
It's distracting, it's annoying.
- [Narrator] But Larry
David wasn't having it.
- Larry David, the hero of this story,
liked that it was annoying.
Said, "Don't you dare. Wolff
you're done here, get out."
And I left and the music
stayed in the picture.
(Theme from Seinfeld)
(single signaling sound)